hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one key idea and you might also say
character that comes up immediately in
Friedrich Nietzsche's thus Spoke
Zarathustra is what in German they call
the ubermensch and it's been translated
in many ways this particular Edition has
Superman but over man
beyond man all sorts of ways and we
ought to point out that mensch doesn't
mean man specifically in terms of gender
it means human beings so we're talking
about a creature or a being that in some
way is beyond or above either can mean
both of those things beyond humanity as
we know it it's still yet connected to
humanity in important ways as we're
going to see Zarathustra himself is not
the ubermensch and Nietzsche doesn't
present himself as being the ubermensch
either and I mentioned that it you could
talk about it as a character it's not a
character who actually shows up on the
scene in the whatever you want to call
this you could call it a sort of novel
in a way by comparison to Nietzsche's
other works or
episodic story or whatever and it's it's
not entirely clear who precisely the
uber mention is supposed to be and
that's the way Nietzsche wants it so if
you're like immediately trying to latch
on to who's the burr mention these days
maybe I'm new burr mention you're not
doober much right Nietzsche would tell
you if you have to ask it's not you so
let's talk about what Nietzsche actually
does tell us about the ubermensch and
especially about the human relationship
to this this whatever it happens to be
sort of a living God on earth except in
a time when gods no longer have this way
that they do so the ubermensch is
presented as someone who is yet to come
and Zarathustra could be likened if you
want to draw analogies to you know John
the Baptist and Jesus in the New
Testament I think that's that's
definitely a parallel that that he
intends and he tells this crowd very
early on in the prologue that he is here
to teach the Superman I teach you the
Superman and then he goes on in the
theme that we're going to explore man is
something that should be overcome what
have you done to over come in so what is
the ubermensch then something that is
beyond humanity but is coming from
humanity in some way as yet to be
determined although Nietzsche gives us
plenty of advice about how we might
bring this about he tells us that the
the Superman is beyond humanity in the
way that humanity is beyond the other
animals and you know there's the animals
in general and then he's got this this
discussion of the worm he says you made
your way from worm to man and much in
you is still worm once you were Apes
even now man is more of an ape than any
ape he who is the wisest among you he is
only a disc or two
hybrid of plants so a vegetative state
you know respiration eating growth
excreting things and of a ghost but I
bid do I bid you to become ghosts or
plants no I teach you the Superman so
the Superman would be beyond the
animality that we still have and and
human beings we should pause on this are
a weird kind of animal according to
Nietzsche we are animals and we have
instincts and drives like all the rest
but ours are weaker more open to
interpretation and we bring about all
sorts of things that in effect transform
our nature and render us no longer just
a naked ape right but rather make us
into a different kind of animal a more
dangerous type of animal but also one
that can live within you know vast herds
as well so the Superman is going to be
beyond that and he also tells us that
the Superman is the meaning of the earth
so what does he mean by that
that's a little cryptic the meaning of
the earth the meaning of this world that
we live in which means that we don't
fully grasp what the meaning of human
existence or the larger you know
ecosystem that we belong to we don't
fully grasp what it is we could imagine
that we do but we would be mistaken
because of that and this is the you know
the source of many human errors
according to Nietzsche we make ourselves
much more important than we are or we
make you know the environment more
important than it is and we don't
recognize that it's the Superman
according to Zarathustra who is the
meaning of the earth he says the
Superman is the meaning of the earth let
your will say the Superman shall be the
meaning of the earth the Superman is not
yet the meaning of the earth which
implies that there's a certain lack of
meaning but this will be made clear when
the Superman show
sup for those of us who are able to
understand this this being now why talk
about the earth why not talk about say
the cosmos or God or something like that
according to Nietzsche we are now in an
age where the highest values have
devalued themselves so he talks about
the death of God for example which is
another topic that we'll get to
eventually the Superman is not supposed
to be simply a replacement for the
judeo-christian God or anything along
those sort of lines some sort of
transcendent value the apex of the
pyramid under which everything else
finds its rightful place this is
supposed to represent a different way of
looking at things a way of viewing
things with no afterlife no transcendent
supernatural just the world that we
actually have and the Superman should be
the meaning the sense of that he also
talks about another key feature of the
Superman something that the ancients
would have called great solidness or to
use the latin 't translation magnanimity
Maga megalo su hain alright that's it to
have the sort of great soul is the way
that Aristotle talks about it we often
translate this as sort of pride but
pride doesn't adequately capture this
the person who is great-souled is in a
certain respect beyond the rest of us he
or she is above us demands great honors
from those who are able to give it not
so much from the common people because
they know they deserve it they're not
vain they're not you know puffer puffing
up their their accomplishments or
anything like that they know their the
thing right and in in how Nietzsche
describes it in the spunk of the earth
is strong we are all sort of like
polluted rivers he talks about man here
we go
what does your body say about your soul
is your soul not poverty and
shirt and a miserable ease in truth man
is a polluted river and then he says
well a polluted river if it flows into
the sea the sea can take that pollution
and dissipate it and it won't be an
issue anymore we can't do that ourselves
we're stuck with our guilty conscience
is and our consciousness of our our
failings and our inability to be to
measure up to these sort of high
standards but the Superman can take all
of that on and allow us to find a kind
of meaning he also talks about it as a
sea in which your great contempt can go
under as well and that's part of why
he's teaching the Superman the last
metaphor that he has in this prologue
about the Superman and he says this in
several different places is that he is
like lightning or rather he is the
lightning and and we could say well what
does that mean to be lightning well
lightning is illuminative but it's not
illuminated the way a lamp is where it
stays on for you know however long we
want it comes and goes as it's going to
and we get a flash and we can suddenly
see everything illuminated and then it's
gone and so I think that is what what
he's suggesting there now that's what
he's saying about the Superman what
about the rest of us what about the
human beings that Zarathustra is
preaching to so here we're talking about
the human relation to the Superman and
you know we could imagine a number of
different relations beyond what
Nietzsche describes we can ignore the
Superman we could say oh we don't want
people like that you know let's let's
pull him down if we see anybody acting
like that let's forget about this but he
just says no there's another possibility
for us and he's sketching this out is
the right way to look at things so again
he tells us that the human being is
between the animal on the one hand and
the Superman on the other hand so he
says that you know man so the Superman
is going to be a laughing
or painful embarrassment why because
that is what the ape is to us so there's
a sort of leveling up you could say that
that's going on but then he also says
that we have a vital role to play he
says that we are and he's using this
metaphor of the tightrope walker we are
a rope fastened between animal and
Superman a rope over an abyss a
dangerous going across a dangerous
wayfaring a dangerous looking back a
dangerous shuddering and staying still
and then he goes on and he says what is
great in humanity is that the person is
a bridge and not a goal what can be
loved in man is that he's are going
across and a down going so our true
value according to this doesn't lie in
ourselves or in humanity with a capital
H or anything along those lines it lies
in the fact that we have the potential
maybe now to realize potential in all
cases but a potential to bridge between
the animal and the superhuman again we
might think of Aristotle and his
discussion in politics book one where he
says that you know the person who can be
entirely on his own must either be an
animal or a god human beings are built
to live within communities and
relationships and that's where we work
out our stuff right so there is the
potential for us to be in some respect
not necessarily divine in the
old-fashioned sense but to be beyond the
human won't be realized in the case of
most or perhaps all of us but we can be
a rope over an abyss an abyss of
meaninglessness of nothingness a bridge
a bridge to something else so how is
this accomplished he tells us that
Humanity is something to be overcome
every other animal
he says has managed to produce something
beyond itself something greater than
itself and you know if you think about
evolution right you know you start out
with this very simple stuff and it gets
greater and greater and greater now you
know we have jokes these days where we
say well you know what is the t-rex turn
into chickens
but in in some respect you know it's
something new it's something beyond
itself right
are we the apex are we where it's
supposed to stop that's a question that
Nietzsche and so many other people were
asking themselves at the time is this
int because if this is it I'm not so
sure that this is the pinnacle of
evolution or development or anything
like that shouldn't we try to produce
something that would be superhuman
something that would be beyond us
that's what Nietzsche thinks that we
ought to do and how would this work he
says that the person the human being has
a lot of different ways in which they
can do this but the key thing to say
here is that it's going to require a
kind of generosity or are not counting
the cost a commitment on one's part to
not expect to even see the Superman and
to have some sort of reward thereby but
just to just to do exactly what one is
supposed to do and thereby pave the way
without expecting to reap the benefits
so he says I love those who do not know
how to live except their lives be a
downgoing
for they're the ones who are going
across Guber again as the commentator
points out is a german term which can
mean many different things including
both the going down and going across and
also destruction so what does this look
like he says I love those who do not
first seek beyond the stars for reasons
to go down and be sacrifices but who
sacrificed themselves to the earth why
not just to sacrifice themselves to the
earth not to be part of some sick
local process but that the earth may one
day belong to the Superman I love him he
goes on who lives for knowledge and who
wants knowledge that one day the
Superman may live by desiring knowledge
by producing knowledge one is hastening
the way to the Superman and he says by
doing this though he wills his own
downfall but he says I love him who
works and invents that he may build a
house for the Superman and prepare earth
animals and plants for him for thus he
wills his own downfall he says I love
him who loves his virtue for revert you
as to will down fall in an arrow of
longing it's a very different conception
of virtue of genuine virtue that
Nietzsche has when we think about you
die monistic ethics we say oh well you
know virtue is its own reward and you
know whether we're looking at
Aristotelian or platonic or stoic or
Christian or whatever sort of view on
virtue like that Nietzsche says no
virtue is something that if you really
have it it consumes you your generosity
or your justice or your courage will in
fact consume you perhaps even bring
about your downfall and by doing so it
brings about in some unexplained way the
advent of the Superman and so he gives
you a whole bunch of examples of this
one that I particularly like is where he
says I love him who throws golden words
in advance of his deeds and always
performs more than he promised for he
wills his own downfall he goes on he
says I love him who justifies the men of
the future and redeems the men of the
past for he wants to perish by the men
of the present there are many different
modes by which a human being would be
the bridge to bring about the Superman
but all of them would demand a kind of
absolute commitment that is not taking
its cues solely from society or past
traditions or even from Nietzsche
himself this would be something that one
would have to work out for oneself
to bring about this human being this new
state of humanity that is yet to come
you